the kind of thing people assume is if
you develop an AGI
that open AI if they're the ones that do
it for example they're going to win but
you're saying no they're everybody loses
yeah it's gonna get better and better
and better and then Kaboom we all lose
that's what's gonna happen when lose and
win are defined in a metric of basically
quality of life
for human civilization and for Sam
Altman both to be blunt my personal
guess you know and people can quibble
with this is that we're just gonna they
won't be any humans that's it that's
what I mean by lose
you know if you if we can see in history
once you have some species or some group
of people who aren't needed anymore
it doesn't usually work out so well for
them right yeah
there were a lot of horses for that were
used for traffic in Boston and then the
car got invented and most of them got
you know well we don't need to go there
and uh if you look at them
humans you know right now we why did the
labor movement succeed and after the
Industrial Revolution because it was
needed
even though we had a lot of mallocs and
there was child labor and so on you know
the company still needed to have workers
and that's why strikes had power and so
on if we get to the point where most
humans aren't needed anymore I think
it's like it's quite naive to think that
they're going to still be treated well
you know we say that yeah yeah um
everybody's equal and the government
will always will always protect them but
if you look in practice
groups that are very disenfranchised and
don't have any actual power
it usually gets screwed
and uh now in in the beginning so
Industrial Revolution
we automated away muscle work
but that got went worked out pretty well
eventually because we educated ourselves
and started working with our brains
instead and got usually more interesting
better paid jobs
but now we're beginning to replace brain
work so we replaced a lot of boring
stuff like we got the pocket calculator
so you don't have people adding
multiplying numbers anymore at work fine
there were better jobs they could get
but now gpt4 you know
and the stable diffusion and techniques
like this they're really beginning to
blow away some real some jobs that
people really loved having it was a
heartbreaking article just post just
yesterday on social media I saw about
this guy who who was doing 3D modeling
for gaming and if
and all of a sudden now they got this
new software he just give says prompts
and he feels his whole job that he loved
it's lost its meaning you know and uh
I asked the gpt4 to rewrite Twinkle
Twinkle Little Star in the style of
Shakespeare
I couldn't have done such a good job it
was really impressive you've seen a lot
of the Arts coming out here right so
I'm all for
automating away the dangerous jobs and
the boring jobs but I think um
you hear a lot some arguments which are
too glib sometimes people say well
that's all that's going to happen we're
getting rid of the boring boring uh
tedious dangerous jobs it's just not
true there are a lot of really
interesting jobs that are being taken
away now journalism is getting going to
get crushed uh coding is going to get
crushed I predict uh the job market for
programmers salaries are going to start
dropping
you know if you said you can code five
times faster you know then you need five
times fewer programmers maybe there will
be
more output also but you'll still end up
using fewer program needing fewer
programmers than today and I love coding
you know I I think it's super cool
um so we we need to stop and ask
ourselves why again are we doing this as
humans like
I feel that AI should be built by
Humanity for Humanity and let's not
forget that it shouldn't be by malloc
for molok or what it really is now is
kind of by Humanity for molok which
doesn't make any sense it's for us that
we're doing it and and um
it would make a lot more sense if we
build develop figure out gradually
safely how to make all this Tech and
then we think about what are the kind of
jobs that people really don't want to
have you know and automate them all away
and then we ask what are the jobs that
people really find meaning in like maybe
taking care of children in the daycare
center maybe doing art etc etc and and
even if it were possible to automate
that away but we don't need to do that
right we built these machines well it's
possible that we
redefine or ReDiscover what are the jobs
that give us meetings yeah for me the
thing it is really sad like I
half the time I'm excited half the time
I'm uh crying as I'm as I'm generating
code because
I kind of love programming it's uh it's
the Act of Creation you you have an idea
you design it and then you bring it to
life and it does something especially if
there's some intelligence that it does
something it doesn't even have to have
intelligence printing hello world on
screen you you you made a little machine
and it it comes to life yeah and uh
there's a bunch of tricks you learn
along the way because you've been doing
it for for many many years and then for
to see AI be able to generate all the
tricks you thought were special yeah
um I don't know it's very uh
it um it's it's scary it's almost
painful like a loss uh loss of Innocence
maybe like yeah maybe when I was younger
uh I remember before I learned that
sugar is bad for you you should be on a
diet
I remember I enjoyed candy deeply in a
way I just can't anymore that I know is
bad for me I enjoyed it unapologetically
fully
just intensely and I just have I lost
that now I feel like a little bit of
that is lost for me with program or
being lost with programming similar as
it is for uh the the 3D modeler no
longer being able to really enjoy the
art of modeling uh 3D things for gaming
I don't know I don't know what to make
sense of that maybe I would ReDiscover
that the true magic of what it means to
be human is connecting with other humans
to have conversations like this I don't
know to uh to have sex to have to eat
food to really intensify the value from
conscious experiences versus like
creating other stuff you're pitching the
rebranding again from homosapiens to
homo sentences but the meaningful
experiences and just to inject some
optimism in this here so we don't sound
like a bunch of gloomers you know we can
totally have our cake and eat it you
hear a lot of totally claims
that we can't afford having more
teachers yeah have to cut the number of
nurses you know that's just nonsense
obviously
with anything even
quite far short of AGI we can
dramatically improve
grow the GDP and produce this wealth of
goods and services it's very easy to
create a world where everybody is better
off than today
including the richest people can be
better off as well right
it's not a zero-sum game you know
technology again
you can have two countries like Sweden
and Denmark had all these ridiculous
Wars Century after century
and uh
sometimes that Sweden got a little
better off because it got a little bit
bigger and then Denmark got a little bit
better off because we can go a little
bit smaller and and but then we then
technology came along and we both got
just dramatically wealthier without
taking away from anyone else it was just
a total win for everyone
and the AI can do that on steroids
if you can build safe AGI
if you can build super intelligence yeah
basically all the limitations that cause
harm today can be complete be completely
eliminated right it's a wonderful you
talk possibility in this this is not
sci-fi this is something which is
clearly possible according to laws of
physics
and I we can talk about ways of making
it safe also
um but unfortunately
that'll only happen if we steer in that
direction that's absolutely not the
default outcome that's why
income inequality keeps going up that's
why the life expectancy in the US has
been going down now I think it's four
years in a row I was just read a
heartbreaking study from CDC about how
something like one-third of all teenage
girls in the US have been thinking about
suicide you know like those are steps
and they're totally the wrong direction
and and it's important to keep our eyes
on the prize here that
we can we have the power now for the
first time in the history of our species
to harness artificial intelligence to
help us really flourish
and help bring out the best in our
Humanity rather than the worst of it
to help us have really fulfilling
experiences that feel truly meaningful
and you and I shouldn't sit here and
dictate the future Generations what they
will be let them figure it out but let's
give them a chance to live and and not
foreclose all these possibilities for
them by just messing things up right